c'est l'image avant et l'
image après du théâtre à maripol qu'on a
évalué et on a catégorisé les dégâts
comme dégâts sévères
[Musique]
étranger en
utilisant des images satellite pour euh pour avoir une
meilleure compréhension de la situation sur
le terrain On compare avant et après
images pour pouvoir les comparer et
comprendre ce qui s'est passé entre les
différentes dates que regardez-vous
ici les différents points de couleur
représentent le niveau de dégâts de
chacun des bâtiments endommagés à mariopul
à cette date donnée
dommages catastrophiques étrangers
[Musique  ]
en bas, il y a un graphique à barres que vous remarquerez
[Musique]
nos principales
responsabilités pour nous assurer que nous
avons des informations disponibles sur les
sites et la situation dans laquelle ils se trouvent pour être
prêts pour la récupération
étrangère